the value of art today is a slippery
topic take a canvas out of the pomp of
an art gallery without the price tag and
many people would find it difficult to
guess the price of the piece like when
Banksy set up a street stand for his art
and almost no one noticed let's see if
you can do better try to guess how much
these pieces of art cost
[Music]
it wasn't always this difficult before
the 20th century especially in Europe
there was a more objective measure of
art there was the hierarchy of genres
codified by the European Academy of Arts
with the highest genre holding more
prestige and cultural value and in
general a great artist was a master
craftsman and intellectual capable of
capturing reality and recreating history
and as you look up and down the
hierarchy it's clear that there's value
given to what is difficult faces which
are the hardest to paint are weighted
the highest unmoving simple objects are
the lowest and excluding moral waiting I
think this is a pretty intuitive
valuation what is difficult is valuable
all of this nicely agreed upon valuation
was ruined by the darkroom now known as
the camera obscura the name comes from
an optical phenomenon where you can
project an image onto a back wall
through a pinhole but the image is very
dim so you have to keep the room almost
totally dark to see it and pretty
quickly many began realizing that with
film that is photosensitive they could
use the darkroom to capture moments
forever
it all happened quickly the first
pictures were taken in the early 19th
century and by the end of that century
the Eastman Kodak company was selling
cameras with film for $1 this shook the
very ground beneath artists feet
remember just before this before
photographs art was the only way of
capturing a moment if you wanted to
remember a view share some technical
idea or even commemorate your kingly
face for posterity
you'd need skill with a quill or the
money to buy it but not anymore
reality could be claimed by anybody in a
bright flash that painted a moment with
photon perfect accuracy with a higher
order of detail than most painters could
dream up take a second what do you do as
an artist what do you do when portraits
life studies even landscapes can be
memorialized without dragging out a pot
of paint or an easel they can be done
cheaper and faster by any untrained
buffoon who's got a buck
what do you do well for artists in the
20th century a wide scattering occurred
with a burst of art that mostly avoided
realism cubism 5 is imposed
Impressionism modernism surrealism there
was tons of abstraction and work to
divide light to copy a looking back it's
not surprising why when photography
bursts into our hands traditional
meaning was lost for a lot of artists
and found again with completely
different roots a lot of modern art is
challenging the very idea of objective
value and meaning art today modern art
doesn't carry an objective or generally
agreed upon value because they lost that
a long time ago instead the value of art
is entirely subjective whatever you
think that piece is worth is what it's
worth and this means that for many who
strike up the intuitive and historical
position that art values should be
related to difficulty there's a paradigm
sized gap between them and the artists
prices and we would do well to observe
the cultural shift here in art and other
places where a technology has made
something easy or automated because the
birth of the darkroom and the way it
shaped art history gives us insights
into how our modern world and
definitions of value might react to the
up ending of human difficulty I want to
be a force for real good in other words
I know that there are bad forces forces
that bring suffering the others and
misery to the world but I want to be the
opposite force I want to be the force
which is truly for good
[Music]
thanks for that video if you liked it
you guys know how to support it all the
links are down below and if you like the
music please go check out Joey pecker ro
and Mecca 83 incredible producers as I'm
sure you heard finally got some exciting
news I'm releasing a new line of
experimental artists it's actually only
one piece of art just one of one you can
like it
[Music]